[Music]
sarah
is next in albany new york hi sarah
what's up
hi dave and rachel thanks for taking my
call today sure how can i help
um so my husband and i are on baby step
3b and we have 23 000 saved towards a
house down payment
wonderful and we are looking at a house
around to uh 250
000 we haven't found one yet but that's
our ideal
number and my husband's parents
um have told us that they have money for
us and
their words are you can either have it
now or after we die
so they have said to us like just give
us a number and we'll give you money
towards the house
and my husband and i are feeling a
little icky about it um
because they gave us money for our
wedding and that didn't go so well that
time around
what do you mean didn't go well um they
gave us
money and then they were upset when we
didn't choose things that they didn't
like
at our wedding
okay how long how long you been married
uh three years okay so it's
pretty new i mean relatively speaking
coming out of that event
and having that you know it's like if it
was 15 years ago it'd probably be a
different discussion
but it's just been three so it's pretty
recent so i
i kind of see two options you guys have
uh the easy option was to say you know
what
it's not worth the relationship stress
it's not worth it my husband i mean you
guys have saved 23 thousand dollars for
your down payment you're almost at 10
percent if you want a 250 000 house
like you guys are rocking it like you're
doing great without their help
um and so you could just keep on
trekking and just saying hey you know
what
you know if they have an inheritance
when they pass that's great that'll just
be
you know a blessing giving desk to
continue their legacy and that's it so
you can go that route and you guys would
be
100 totally fine if you went the route
where you said okay maybe we do
take a little now to help us kind of
jump start the house process you would
just have to have
extremely clear boundaries
and lots of communication and and it
to the point that you're like okay you
know what this happened at the wedding
have you guys have you guys had a
conversation about what happened with
the wedding and the money
definitely not because it got really
awkward yeah mom
actually like hung up on him because we
didn't do something right with the
flowers
that she wanted and it was like the
first time she had ever hung up on him
so it was it was a really weird
situation and it felt
strange absolutely well there's some
dysfunction there i mean right i mean
like that's that's a
pretty big statement and so i would say
um
if if you guys go forward you have to go
back and revisit
and say hey this is our experience with
you guys with the money we were very
thankful that you guys gave us this
amount but this conflict happened it
made us very uncomfortable
and so how can we assure that that's not
going to happen again that if we choose
to use this money in a way that maybe
you don't approve of the house we're
going to buy like how is that going to
make you guys feel we don't want to make
you uncomfortable we don't make you
angry so if it's easier for the
relationship
maybe we just hold off but i just see
that lots of communication
around these topics you kind of just get
the get the funk out of the air
talk about it but then you guys have to
know that like you cannot control their
response
and how they choose to respond is up to
them
and so my knee-jerk reactions here if i
was in your position it's probably just
not worth it
and i'm like you know what i think we're
gonna be fine on our own doing our own
thing
um instead of messing with it okay yeah
if you are gonna go i forward i would
what rachel said
i i i think it's your husband's job
because it's his parents
um there is a possibility that
the house sits in a different place in
his mom's emotions
than you stealing her baby boy
that was a thing so
[Laughter]
in other words she might not be as
emotionally invested in the house deal
as she was in the wedding deal
that's a possibility so we we could give
her a little bit of grace in that regard
uh but but i think he's got to sit down
with his mom and dad and probably
maybe you're not even there or if you're
there you don't say a word
that sounds good to me and uh he needs
to handle his parents
because otherwise you'll you're gonna
end up at the narrative is you're the
bad guy
yeah we don't want you being the bad guy
at the end of this because
and it would just sound like mom and dad
listen i mean mom you hung up on me
over the flowers at the wedding and felt
like you had the right to tell us how to
do things at the wedding because of the
gift
if this gift for the home has that kind
of a thing going
it's not it's not worth it and we don't
want to do it
but if you can assure us that you allow
us to make our decisions about our house
and you'll enjoy our purchase with us
then we would love to accept the gift
but we can't
if there's if we're because i i don't
want you angry with me
again uh if i if i if i buy a house that
you know
doesn't have enough trees to suit you or
something you know i don't know what the
flip is you gotta guest bedroom
yeah yeah that doesn't you don't like
the guest bedroom yeah because also the
truth
of just like the human condition is it
wasn't the flowers truly the flowers
that set her off it's truly not gonna be
the specific house
it's everything underneath that that's
going on in her whether it's the control
aspect whether it's you took her baby
boy from like whatever
it is there's that underlying thing
that's under there that's kind of her
issue yeah and so it's just to the point
of like okay do you want to do you want
to face it and honestly money
i talk about this in my book know
yourself know your money the boundaries
that you have to have
in relationships with people whether
it's friendships or in-laws
or family whatever it is that those
boundaries are so crucial because money
makes things so
strange and you choosing not to take the
money is not you avoiding it i think it
could be you guys being wise and just
saying you know what there's other
issues there that she has
and more than likely it's a reflection
of her and that may not have changed in
three years
if you think that having that
conversation will clear it up
then you can consider it if you think
there's a 50 50 chance that conversation
clears it up
or less don't consider it just walk away
yeah
but it you guys know more how things
have been during the three years since
and so forth
than anybody else maybe she's just
having a really bad week you know i
don't know
but uh uh it's an emotional thing to go
through a wedding for all parties
involved not just the bride
and so um having done three
weddings with three of our kids uh i've
experienced that as the dad
and i've watched the various moms
experience it different ways
and so uh in just the ramsey house
anyway so
uh it's a process to go through
emotionally
so yeah